"Swing Carcass" and 7 Other Language Facts
1) The term “Swiss Army Knife” was coined
by United States soldiers after WWII.
The soldiers had trouble pronouncing the original
name of “Schweizer Offiziersmesser” (Swiss
Officer’s Knife) and thus began calling
the multi-tool a “Swiss Army Knife”.
The company that makes Swiss Army Knives is
Victorinox, named after the founder, Karl
Elsener’s, deceased mother, Victoria.
The “nox” part comes from the fact that
stainless steel is also known as “inox”,
which is short for the French term “inoxydable”.
Karl Elsener himself was originally the owner
of a surgical equipment company.
He later took over production of the original
Modell 1890 knives, which were previously
made in Germany.
He moved the production to Switzerland and
greatly improved the design of the original
multi-tool.
His big breakthrough came when he figured
out a way to put blades on both sides of the
handle using the same spring to hold both
sides in place.
This allowed him to put twice as many features
into the multi-tool as was previously possible.
2) Miss Piggy’s full name is “Pigathia
Lee”, as revealed on episode 106 and 116
of The Muppet Show.
‘Pigathia’ is derived from ‘Piganthius’,
which is Greek for “river of passion”.
3) The USDA defines “bacon” as “the
cured belly of a swine carcass”… mmm swine
carcass…
And if you’re wondering, the difference
between bacon and salted pork or ham is primarily
just the composition of the brine that is
used to cure it.
Brine for bacon often includes sodium nitrite,
sodium nitrate, and saltpeter (for curing
the meat); sodium ascorbate (for setting the
color, as well as speeding up the curing process);
and brown or maple sugar (for flavor), among
other ingredients.
Brine for ham tends to have a significantly
higher concentration of sugar.
4) The term “latrine” comes from the Latin
“lavare”, which means “to wash”.
The earliest references to this word being
used in English goes all the way back to the
mid-17th century.
5) The term “toilet” comes from the French
“toilette”, meaning “dressing room”.
“Toilette” in turn derives from the French
“toile”, meaning “cloth”.
During the 17th century, the toilet was simply
the process of getting dressed, fixing your
hair, applying make-up and the like.
This gradually began to refer to the items
around where someone was groomed, such as
the table and powder bottles.
In the 19th century in America, this term
began referring to both the room where people
got dressed and ready for the day, as well
as the device now most commonly known as the
toilet.
6) The standard responses to “ahoy”, when
used in nautical terms, vary depending on
who’s on the boat being hailed.
If you have a commissioned officer aboard,
“aye aye” is the correct response.
If no officer is aboard, “no no” is the
correct response.
If a captain of a different ship is on board,
the name of the ship is the proper response.
Finally, if an admiral is aboard the vessel,
the proper response is “flag”.
7) The first known reference of the term “Pop”,
as referring to a beverage, was in 1812 in
a letter written by English poet Robert Southey.
In this letter, he also explains the term’s
origin: “Called on A. Harrison and found
he was at Carlisle, but that we were expected
to supper; excused ourselves on the necessity
of eating at the inn; supped there upon trout
and roast foul, drank some most admirable
cyder, and a new manufactory of a nectar,
between soda-water and ginger-beer, and called
pop, because ‘pop goes the cork’ when
it is drawn, and pop you would go off too,
if you drank too much of it.”